okay so this is the last part of the
workshop thanks thank you guys for
sticking through to the
to the very end um so it's been a really
interesting day of talks where we've
tried to bring together
um
fields that i think don't typically talk
much to each other so there there's um
so both ross and matalina's talk
we're focusing on trying to understand
the
the psychology of social norms and so
sort of how people's
beliefs are
influenced by um by other people and in
sort of
uh multi-subject scenarios
um and that's really about sort of sort
of the science of human cognition and
how people
how individuals think and then um we had
uh
nice sort of more more machine learning
oriented talks by natasha and eugene and
patrick that were about how in
multi-agent uh specifically
reinforcement learning systems how we
can use social coordination between
these agents to sort of
um
improve their performance and then
as a final sort sort of touch i think
raphael's work and and his talk sort of
pushes
um
yet so sort of a third axis that is how
can we use
uh human and
uh
ai
interaction so
incorporating human preferences into
ai
learning to come up with
new types of
social norms that
reflect the human preferences but but
can be learned in in ways that can maybe
scale or that are sort of
more
more robust
so
everyone uh here has been introduced
except for fernando so let me just take
a moment to introduce him so he's uh
he's uh
uh
he did his phd in lisbon and sort of a
sort of physics-y uh oriented uh
um i actually don't know what the actual
degree i guess it was a computer science
degree yeah right so computer science um
but he then worked then went uh to the
states and worked with simon
levin who's a
notable sort of broad evolutionary
biologist that i think does lots of
uh different interesting sort of
evolutionary game theory population
decision making collective phenomena
um type of questions and now he's he's
he's back in europe uh in a position at
the university of amsterdam where he i
think he he sort of sort of
he shares this
this goal of sort of pushing these ideas
both uh theoretically and sort of how we
understand collective decision making
into applied uh applied problems which i
think is is really interesting and
that's actually specifically why i i
thought he would be a nice
um addition to the
to the panel okay so with the stage set
uh now we can start discussing right how
do we start this multi-agent uh
trajectory of of transmission of ideas
and and stuff um
so
uh
because of this sort of sort of disjoint
okay maybe i shouldn't say it's disjoint
but this
these different directions from which
everyone is coming i'd like to maybe get
each panelist's view on
um what they think is sort of the main
next thing that
should be focused on in order to try to
integrate
these these different
perspectives is it um
is it trying to
develop
better
theory but behind the experiments is is
it about increasing the the sort of sets
of tasks that that we sort of test these
um our our science on um
or for instance is it uh doing more
ethology just going out and seeing
um
what is out there in more real life
um scenarios
so is there who who would like to
take a stab well i think the potential
collaboration is pretty easy for all of
us i feel like in a sense like i was
thinking like especially raphael um
mentioned his talk just like
right we need some sort of model of
human behavior generally um
if the goal is to
you know develop human compatible agents
that requires you know training in the
middle across millions of i mean your
case um fewer than millions of steps but
like the same with like the overcooked
work referenced before
um
my talk on
kind of more on the movement dynamic
side and then the talks by
madeline as well talk about talking
about kind of the
social social norm side as well as these
two as well
um that i think that's kind of the
exciting area of collaboration is kind
of combining the expertise from those in
reinforcement learning with those from
social psychology perception action
and kind of
exploiting
at least our best approximations of
human models of behavior um to help
facilitate at least kind of maybe warm
start the design of the training of
agents um to collaborate with humans um
yeah that was my initial thought from
after all these stocks
i guess maybe we could trade off with
zoom
sure
fernando or madeline do you want to uh
yeah i can i can say something i hope
the sound is okay in that room yes um
well thanks a lot for the invitation
sorry for not
being present to here to the talks but
but i agree with the previous comment
that i think there's a lot of um
future in the interface of the different
disciplines
computer science social psychology
and just to give some context one
one topic that i'm
very interested in is
social norms in the sense of rules that
define
what is right or wrong in terms of
cooperation with specific agents
in systems called indirect reciprocity
so if i cooperate
with a certain agent that this agent did
not
was not cooperative in the past
should i have a good or a bad reputation
should i actually be
assessed as being
valuable or not
so there's some theoretical knowledge
about these there's some
um
empirical knowledge there's some nice
experiments in social psychology
and i guess another interface and
combining human agent interactions for
instance human robot interactions i
think there's a lot of opportunities
here
for for future research on
for example are people
as likely to are people evaluating
cooperation with other humans as they
are evaluating cooperation with the
machine or an artificial agent so
so i completely agree the previous point
in the interface of the different
disciplines there's the future
yeah i guess i want to bounce off that
and something that was said earlier but
like a specific thing that i'm very
excited about at the interface
is uh making things that are currently
implicit in human behavior models that
are learned with machine learning like
more explicit right so
um in in like driving land uh a lot of
the way that we build our human behavior
models is we get these like big
trajectories uh and you know we fit some
function that uh predicts the future
evolution of the trajectory from some
past chunk of trajectory
um i really think one way that we we get
the
uh the amount of data required down and
we get good generalization is not
figuring out ways to build explicit like
cognitive models
uh models of like human sensing
capabilities and things like that into
those imitation processes
um like i think that that will
uh
be really impactful for kind of like
imitation learning and and human human
modeling using ml
uh and this is very much inspired by
well
i i only think this
i think that models of humans might work
because of raphael's work because it
worked and i i wouldn't have bet that it
worked
so
uh
yeah uh yeah so more more explicit
integration of things that we've learned
from like cognitive science and
neuroscience into
the ml like fitting loop i think that's
gonna be great
if i can go next um
thanks i i totally agree and i'm really
excited that you guys are building these
panels so interdisciplinary because this
is exactly what i'm trying to do as i
start a lab and trying to to become more
interdisciplinary myself and try to get
these questions from all these different
angles because
like you all said i also strongly
believe that it's at our intersection
that we're gonna make a lot more
progress at this point
um and and so i'm excited to to start
collaborating with
machine learners and and others to to
get at these these um questions from a
lot of angles and what i think is
very interesting right now is the way in
the ways in which we can contribute our
expertise to really start to get
a bigger sense a better sense of our
processes that we're interested in for
example
we can do in psychology
these experiments that are very highly
controlled however
they don't really scale in the way that
your you know agent-based models would
um and that's that's a point of
connection that i think it's very
meaningful and that i'm really i'd be
really excited to collaborate on
and then on the other hand you know you
guys build all these models that are
informed by human cognition
but you know you need to test them out
back into the field and see how kind of
they
um apply and track with with what is
actually going on in terms of whether
whether or not they actually predict um
human behaviors in different
circumstances in ways that are you know
responsive to all of the complexities of
human interactions and human cultures
and i think that's something that we're
going to have
to have a lot more dialogue um
to to be able to figure out so thanks
for this invitation and
um i really hope we we would we'll be
able to to get some collaborations going
um so i think both at this workshop but
also at the posters and the main talks
there were a lot of different
like a lot of similar uh
problems that were like approached in
different ways of like do you
uh use
uh imitation learning do you use inverse
rl or like how do you try to
um
yeah do you want to build a simulation
or do you just go from a fixed data set
like
and i
don't have a good way of navigating what
is the most appropriate method for which
problem
and i think
uh
so for me it's like personally i just
used what i thought was like the most
standard way and i want to like make it
harder until that stops working then i
think it will be really exciting to go
back to all of the ideas that were
floating around at this conference to
sort of find the most appropriate ones
that range from
also yeah how um
ross started with um you know
very psychological ideas of like
parameters like two parameters you can
fit that like determine the behavior or
um yeah i'll set the main conference of
those different ideas that were floating
around
did you want to ask her
maybe
apparently
i was just going to say that i am also
very curious when raphael stuff stops
working and when it does you should
announce it to the world because i i'm
so curious when it stops scaling maybe
it never stops scaling
i just need to
know okay so that's good because
my question gonna be a bit about
our
strong priors about scale is all you
need or reward is all you need or item
speech is all you need
and we see with the the work of raphael
for instance how
we can step out of our
policy
and discover even new form of mechanisms
and
with madalina we we so also why we
should maybe do that as a society
uh so
i i i want to ask the
[Music]
everybody here like
what would be according to you maybe the
the belief of the field
that may be
the the strongest to
uh modulate maybe to to go in that
direction
and like
uh
in the principles or the
the way the the field of reinforcement
learning and decision making has been
taking those problems
yeah like which are the social norms
that we should be studying
typically but for instance uh yesterday
we discussed about for instance how
multi-agent reinforcement learning was
kind of uh
a side marginalized part of iran for
instance but i i was surprised as an
outsider
because i think like merchants dynamics
could really bring new principles or so
so i would be curious to have also ideas
from people who are more within the
field
i'd be interested no as well
from someone who's not from an ml
background
okay so i'm going to try to avoid saying
something that prevents us from
recording this
um
so uh
i i think if we if we go back to
natasha's talk for a second like
natasha provides an argument for for why
there are benefits to to viewing the
multi-agent perspective
uh for deploying something in a world
where imitation and social learning is
possible and could be an efficient way
of learning about the world it's not the
only way you could do it differently but
maybe maybe it's a faster way to learn
about the world than other alternatives
um the other thing i guess i would say
is that like
um
i think i think that i believe is that
there are more that there's more than
one way to be intelligent and there is
more than one way to structure
interaction between many agents right
there are many different protocols you
could have for interaction between
different agents
and we want our agents to
operate in human society which is a
particular set of protocols and a
particular way of learning about the
world
and
the the multi-agent dynamics
kind of a
shape the type of intelligence that
emerges that you will get a different
way of viewing and thinking and
operating in the world when you are part
of like a long
chain of like
multi-agent interactions which which we
all are um so
i think i think there's like you know
interesting questions about
uh the ways that multi-asian
interactions shape human intelligence uh
about how to
use multi multi-multi-interactions to
speed up learning and sharing of
information and so on
um and and i think that there are
for for deploying agents that operate in
the world with humans uh very particular
questions we need to answer about how
like humans operate
um
so
uh
maybe i went off on a segway there but
uh
yeah that's okay
yeah but instead of false agent rl being
a side like a side project i feel like
it should be the first project the
primary i mean just if if the goal is to
resemble human mic intelligence i mean
just like clearly from like
developmental psychology like we're born
into very
so you know social worlds our
environments are actively constructed by
those around us and stuff and concepts
like in natashas talk about social
learning for example where there's clear
benefits
um
for observing the actions of others um
if you just take it simply as
you know the search space is so so huge
that in order for you to develop good
policies in order to develop you know
adaptive behavior you kind of do need to
rely on the experiences of others around
you um that's my take yeah i just want
to push back a tiny little bit on one
thing so we've gotten if we had started
with multi-agent rl if that had been the
first thing we tried to do we wouldn't
have gotten all these like nice
algorithms that now underlie the basis
of multi-agent rl like there's there's a
lot to be to be taken by like trying to
study the single agent learning
perspective a lot we've gotten out of
that so
um
yeah that's fair yeah
i think what uh josh tenenbaum said
earlier which was that he was sort of
telling everyone at the conference
you're trying to recreate evolution
uh and it might take a whole planet and
billions of years i think the
multi-agent rl is take is sort of that's
the natural conclusion of that i think
of just
trying to if if the task is constantly
set by other agents that are also
learning and you make each other better
and better and better you can just have
like an open-ended process that will if
the world is complex enough and if
everybody's getting smarter and smarter
it will just end up hopefully producing
a very general
uh
intelligence that's the idea but it's a
question of like would it
is that one you want to interact with or
can or do you have to like
uh affect it a bit more to make it
compatible with humans or
guide it a bit more to end up where we
want it to end up
yeah i think i think just the sort of
something that ravel had in there was
like this auto curriculum hypothesis
where like intelligent agents push on
each other and spur the the development
of further intelligence um
and i i guess uh there's there's a
second component of that which is really
nice is that like it kind of takes the
human out of the loop like we don't have
to sit there continually designing new
complicated problems that we think will
make our agents a little better and a
little better and yeah there's like a
really nice aspect that you get out of
multi-agent from that too
also like to to precise
the angle uh
i wanted to have was also uh in the
context of climate change for instance
or social inequality
uh how for instance we discussed with
michael yesterday
uh focusing on minimizing regret instead
of
maximizing
value or profit
would drastically change over
a long term
the kind of
mechanisms and technologies that we are
designing
like that
i was shocked sometimes at conference
being an outsider of certain claim to me
songs like almost ideological
at the economical level
and like for instance never i never seen
for instance poster talking about
illinois ostrom or uh more like uh
commons good and stuff like that for
instance
fernando maybe you want to comment
having the the background in
evolutionary game theory and sort of uh
public good dilemmas
yeah i was i was
listening and thinking um
on this idea of um
if multi-agent rl now one of the goals
is to you know a replicate evolution how
that
might take the whole planet and
and i was thinking how
even if you take apart a lot of the
complexities that
we developed um as humans in the long
run
um
complexity complexes related with
perception with computer vision with
uh with movement in the world so there's
a lot of
a lot of these components that even if
we take them apart we still have
fascinating challenges related with
solving
cooperation valuem solving
the exact same problems that elena
rostrum um
attempt to solve or study on governing
the comments on on
so all of these i think
multi-agent rl even if it doesn't aim
in the long run to solve all the
the
the complexities that we humans evolved
to solve at some point i think would be
um
fantastic if it at least solves the and
governing the comments type of dilemmas
um
[Music]
and um
and i also want to bring the idea that
um of course now we are thinking how um
how humans how social
or social psychology how um
how observing human behavior might
inspire multi-agent reinforcement
learning algorithms and new techniques
but the other way around is also true in
the sense that by
looking to these to the complex dynamics
that emerge
in multi-agent rl
might also learn about new perspectives
of
where to look in terms of new
experiments to understand human behavior
um
which i'm not sure it was entirely
related to the question that was posed
before but this is also a direction that
i'm quite fascinated about
on how to use the most recent multi
um ancient rl
algorithms or multiplication systems or
even evolutionary theoretical tools and
how to employ those to
steer the direction of
social psychology experiments or
economics
also i
a identify on the answer i'm not sure it
doesn't exclude
the question
okay
um it connects also with one of the
questions that we prepared about like
how the the
medium of the communication
shaped the the process of social
non-creation maintenance and so on and
madalena for instance present well
in the case of the sources of the
information for instance it can play a
big role so that's also maybe uh
a way to change how we're looking at
those problem of uh governance of
commands like
the introduction of the signaling and
the modality
as topics of study you know yeah people
study more than sort of like a marshall
mcluhan thing yeah
i mean it's not because we are from do
you have maybe some comments on that
madalina
yeah so
that's interesting because
you mentioned the source and that's just
one thing that can vary you know like
that's one of the complexities which we
can play with and see what happens
but even if we focus on that one you
know
variable that we want to look at which
is the source
even there
we observe different types of effects
depending on different situations so
there's one context in which one source
is more
effective depending on what your goal is
say your goal is to change someone's
belief there's a context in which
also depending on the belief or
depending on on other features of the
context like spatial temporal uh
features so my point is that there's all
these complexities that you just
have to account for uh in experiments we
can control for them
but it just depends on on what your
question is i guess but what we find for
example in a couple of experiments is
that
um
if if you're trying to change a
political belief for instance
um i think i mentioned this in my talk
uh the the best source the most
effective source would be
um
would be a non-denominated
large group of other people and and we
would have thought that the best source
would be someone who you identify with
so for example for
republican participants we thought they
would be more convinced by a group of
republican
people who want to change their mind and
that wasn't the case so in this one
instance you know we were we were kind
of shocked by this um result but also we
have to keep in mind that there's other
features of the context that that
shape these results and they shape them
according to the
socio-political context under which
we're asking these questions and all of
that so
um i think there's there's a huge level
of
of complexity that is at play here and
it just um
there's i think there's a lot to
to dig
before we can
have some clear answers on
you know even a simple question as what
the source effects might be on
social influence for instance
yeah i think the point that madeleine
right madalina just raised there is like
very
very interesting and kind of goes back
to the point you were making about
reward maximization because i'm not
i'm being speculative here but i'm not
certain that like a rational reward
maximizing agent gets gets the place
where it like does its
updates its belief less on things that
are like on from agents that are like it
than like a non-denominational set like
i think that's like a very particular
thing i don't know that you get that in
a reward maximization framework of a
single agent it's like seems weird to me
if that was true
yeah
well it's connect for instance with
active learning or
active inference where you have a reward
not for just like value but also for
epistemic uh
update of your beliefs
well the the reward people would say
that like that's just emergent from
trying to maximize your reward yeah okay
i think like in a way also maybe it's a
uh
a semantic thing that could become
ideological if you take the the term
reward uh straightforwardly yeah
i think if i
may i think my my whole um kind of talk
kind of hinged on this idea that there's
processes
cognitive processes that we observe
that kind of um
go a little bit of against what we would
expect a rational agent to do
so so
most of my experiments show that look
the rational agent model would predict
this to happen
and we observe in these experiments that
human behavior human cognitive functions
kind of don't always follow that
expectation so
a lot of
social and cognitive psychology right
now are trying to understand what causes
these
differences between you know just taking
a step further from the rational model
and trying to understand
what
what are the other features that explain
all of these behaviors and decisions
um that the that the rational agent
model can't explain
and
yeah i think um i think it's
in in in our view at least from this
point of social psychology at the moment
there's these two forces and i guess you
can call them the the reward maximizing
function
but
the two forces that pull
people's behaviors in in this
new view
are
the people are trying to be
rational and trying they have this
accuracy goal
but then an equally or maybe even
stronger
motivational force
is this
identity-based
social cognition which pulls people in
this direction of well rationally i
should do this but
because i'm motivated to align with my
group i will
um
engage in all these other
cognitive functions and cognitive
processes that will
lead the outcome to be a little bit
further from what the rational model
would say so
i think having both of these views in
taking them into account and um
and understanding kind of how both of
them
could be
what people are trying to maximize
is something that we could i think start
a conversation about because it's a lot
of what the discussion in um a lot of
the social sciences is right now
i was wondering if
this thought about you know how humans
don't expect this rational type of
behavior i mean well there's you know
heuristic following itself but is it
possible where we define these reward
functions
so if you were to take a reward function
is a single a scalar representation of a
task
and that
you know when we're you know
just in general like we're not engaged
in any given task at any given time in
the sense that you know there's at least
okay you might be engaged in a task but
right there's like task competition i
suppose and things are drawing your
attention away i don't know i'm trying
to think of like paul scheck or
something like the affordance
competition
idea that um
i'm wondering if you were if i don't
know if you guys had a specific thought
in the sense of like
you know you
maybe if this relates to like auxiliary
reward functions for example almost like
yeah just like
task competition
um
maybe sometimes
just to be clear that like rational is
is a is in some sense a technical term
tied to a particular objective rational
means best with respect to a given
objective
and so the question is well what are the
objectives
and which one should we build into the
agents and
how can we infer
human objectives which is a
traditionally quite hard problem you can
even do
algorithms like inverse reinforcement
learning on human behavior to infer
what reward functions are but that's
still going to depend on the model that
you choose for the
for the agent
so
yes i think it's an
excellent point and actually
even within a context where
there's homogenizing the reward
functions of agents and even if
within this framework of reward
maximization
only accounting for symmetries in
exposure to information for example
and
biases in how individuals might
exacerbate or disregard that information
that might
provide some explanations or that might
provide some justification for why you
observe seemingly irrational behaviors
around this
and there might be situations where
um these type of perception biases might
be maladaptive there's situations where
these perception biases might actually
lead to improvements
um so within the framework of
evolutionary game theory
something that we've been working on
understanding in the context of
cooperation dilemmas and collective
action dilemmas how these biases and our
exposure to different sources of
information
might lead to benefits or
um
just collective failures in the long run
which is something that perhaps also
within multi-agent reinforcement
learning so i'm not i'm not i don't know
of any works maybe you know in the room
about uh
works on how these information
symmetries or
biases in interpreting information
impact multi-agent reinforcement
learning dynamics
but i think that might perhaps be an
interesting point to discuss at some
point
yeah uh yeah we can take
some questions from the audience if
you guys can share
yeah thanks for all those thought
provoking discussions uh i guess one
thing
that just built off of what we have been
talking about
uh you got you guys have been talking
about
is that in some time
in some cases people do not behave as
they believe
and i think people believe in that right
it's very obvious that i think amazon is
evil like keep buying things from them
and if you ask me that doesn't make
sense i was like i know
but but i don't i don't care right so
it's a very common
discrepancy between what people's
reasoning lead to
and what their actions lead to and then
what that challenge in in both i think
ai community and behavioral science
community
is that we uh we build model off of
people's action
right even the rational like most of the
computational literature in um in for
example irl
or uh or inverse planning is
designing environments and we we infer
based upon the agents or
human subjects behavior
right so in that context it's successful
because we are uh judging based upon
their actions and uh there's another
line of work like uh um
excuse me i pronounced the name
incorrectly madelina that right
madeline's work is not really uh
modeling based at least not as the one
she presented and that's uh in a way has
its advantage in that it's it's more
about people's uh mental reasoning and
measures more language based so i think
i'm curious about your thoughts on uh
what do you think of this discrepancy
and how can we
merge this right of course we want to
model everything if possible but it
seems there is a difficulty in capturing
some of the richness of human language
semantics and human belief as it's been
described by the natural language
instead of
some more quantifiable way as
modelers typically study it
yeah i don't know if i made myself clear
on that
yeah thank you for that question i i
think a lot about that and it's a really
great question and it's really uh on
everyone's mind i think at the moment
why is there this big disconnect between
people's beliefs and their behaviors
their actions um
that's something that
there's so many there's so many
theoretical models in social psychology
like old school like from 100 years ago
where they're trying to say like wait
like we kind of think beliefs should
predict behaviors and they do sometimes
but
there's all of these interactions with a
lot of different forces that will
produce all of these confound
conflicting conflicting findings and you
will find that there's these instances
in which beliefs do predict behaviors so
um i actually picked up this line of
work a few years ago because after
giving my talk on belief change
almost 100 of the time that question is
that does that translate into behavioral
change
so i had to i had to figure it out um
so so
the literature at least in psychology is
that it is very
conflicting so on on the one hand
there's
there's situations in which beliefs
predict behaviors very strongly so for
example
um at least correlationally uh religious
beliefs predict learning success oh
sorry religious beliefs predict crime
rates
um
very strongly then
beliefs about intelligence predict
learning success
and beliefs about
health uh
health behaviors predict those behaviors
so there's particular instances under
which this disconnect um isn't there but
then there's instances in which for
example your belief about an outgrowth
member um
does not predict your your interactions
with that output member and doesn't
predict your uh behaviors uh when you're
interacting with them so
we're trying to disentangle right now
what are these situations does the
beliefs interact with social norms and
do social norms trump beliefs when when
they go head head head and head
or um or are there other features that
that interacts with this um just
creating this super complex model
so that's what we're doing right now
trying to understand this in the context
of climate action
so i i mentioned briefly this um study
we're launching we've launched uh
already
on understanding collective climate
action
so we're uh deploying a massive
randomized control trial in over 80
countries
and trying to understand first of all
why are the psychological drivers of
climate action so what are these
interventions that we
as policy makers for example
can really use and be effective in
getting people to individually change
their behaviors
change their voting behaviors at the
collective level so support climate
policy which
um actually has pretty low support
because it would raise taxes so it's
like a
it's like a duality like um you would
gain something at the collective level
but you lose something at the individual
level um and so
so in this kind of context we're trying
to bridge the gap because we'll have a
huge data set
and we'll have all these
different psychological mechanisms by
which we'll be able to see when beliefs
predict behaviors and when they don't so
this is something i'm looking forward to
in in this data set that will be
collected by the end of this year
but other than this there's experiments
that we're doing trying to understand
what what are these situations under
which we can bridge this belief behavior
gap
um there's also a huge um
intention action gap so people
let alone believe but intention to
behave in some certain way like my
intention can be to vote and on the on
the day of i i might not actually go
through with it so there's another
huge field trying to bridge the
intention action gap and there's
there are some pretty good um
interventions there that have been shown
um
uh pretty pretty promising at bridging
that gap
so i can go into that if you if you're
interested but
that's just like at the top of my mind
at this at this moment
thanks marlena
um so uh eugene just had to leave
because he has to catch a flight like
right now and he had he had told me
beforehand so uh
um
thanks eugene
um
yeah i don't know um there's just i mean
we should probably wrap up soon but um
i think we've
we've covered quite a bit um
yeah i think this this uh this workshop
has tried to sort of cover both um
the ai alignment
problem to some extent but i think it's
it's also revealed that there's sort of
a
there's there's a complex way in which
like the human
value alignment problem is also going to
play a role in uh
in that and uh let's hope that
you know we can design ai that that
contributes positively to that
um
so uh we are running a little behind
schedule so why don't we why don't we
end it here and just thank all the
speakers for their great talks and
contributions they should be available
online in the next couple of days so uh
yeah thanks again everyone
thank
you everyone
um
did you just close it
you